.
FULTON COUNTY DIFFICULT A ALSO
ALICE ASKED THE FBI TO TIGHTEN
SECURITY AT BUILDINGS AROUND HER
OFFICE.
FANNY WILLIS REQUESTED THIS AND
JOINS US NOW.
NOW THAT THE ZR SPECIAL GRAND
JURY MANZ BEEN SELECTED, CAN YOU
TELL PEOPLE WHO YOU PLAN TO
BRING IN AS WITNESSES?
OBVIOUSLY, THE CALL BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND RAFFENSPERGER.
>> I CAN'T DISCUSS SPECIFIC
PEOPLE.
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU IS DURING
THE POINT TO THIS POINT WE HAVE
HAD AN GUESS OF 50 PEOPLE WHO
HAVE DEVINED TO TALK TO US
VOLUNTARILY.
AND SO, WHAT WE PLAN TO DO IS
START SERVING THEM THINK
SUBPOENAS OR ATTORNEYS SO THEY
CAN HEAR FROM THEM.
>> WHAT POWER DO THEY HAVE TO
RESISTANT THOSE SUBPOENAS?
>> I AM SURE THERE WILL BE
FOEGZS TO QUASH MILED BUT I AM
AL CONFIDENT THE JUM OVER THIS
THE SPECIAL PURPOSE GRAND JURY
AS LONG AS WE MEET
TECHNICALITIES AND DO THINGS OF
COURSE WE PLAN TO DO, THOSE
SUBPOENAS WILL BE EP FORCED AND
THEY WILL BE BEFORE THE
SPECIAL-PURPOSE GRAND JURY AND
AND TESTIFY.
>> AND AS I UNDERSTAND, THE
SPECIAL GRAND JURY, THEY WILL
HAVE AUTHORITY SPO SUBPOENA
WITNESS BS DOCUMENTS, ASK -- ASK
THEIR OWNS.
BUT IT CAN ONLY RECOMMEND
CRIMINAL CHARGES.
THE ACTUAL-CHARGING DECISION
FALLS TO YOU.
DO YOU HAVE A TIMELINE FOR A
CHARGELINGING DECISION?
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
A SPECIAL PURPOSE GRAND JURY
DOES HAVE SOME POWERS AND ONE
THOSE IS THAT THEY CAN, ON THEIR
OWN, ASK NOR FOR SSH DOCUMENTS
TO BE PREPONDERANCE SPOOENED OR
IF ONE WITNESS WE BRIDGE IN
MENTIONS SOMEONE AND THINK IT IS
RELEVANT, THEY CAN REQUEST THOSE
PEOPLE BE BROUGHT IN, AND NOT
REQUEST BUT ACTUALLY HAVE A
SUBPOENA ISSUED TO BRIDGE THOSE
IN SO THAT IS AN AWESOME POWER
AND RESPONSIBILITY.
IN TERMS OF A TIMELINE?
I HAVE JUST FOLLOWED THE KOURTS
WE ARE GOING TO LET THE EVIDENCE
TAKE US WHERE MAY.
WE HAVE ONE YEAR TO DO THIS SO
FROM MAY, TODAY, THROUGH MAY
31st, OF 2023, I DO NOT
ANTICIPATE IT IS TO TAKE THAT
LONG, THOUGH, BUT THAT WOULD BE
HOW LONG WE HAD.
>> AND -- CAN AND YOU JUST TALK
ABOUT THE SCOPE OF YOUR
INVESTIGATION?
WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU LOOKING AT?
>> WE GOING TO LOOK A THE
ANYTHING CONNECT WITH
INTERFERENCE WITH THE 2020
ELECTION.
SO I HAVE ALLOWED THAT TO BA
BROAD SCOPE, NOT JUST THE
PRESIDENT'S PHONE CALL PLAYED
THERE BUT OTHER THINS THAT
INDICATE THERE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
INTERFERENCE WITH THAT ELECTION.
TO INCLUDE, FAKE ELECTORATES.
>> I'M SORRY, TO INCLUDE?
>> FIK ELECTORATES.
I KNOW I WERE AWARE THAT WAS
DONE IN OUR STATE SO THAT IS OF
INTEREST TO MY OFFICE.
>> THE FAKE ELECTORS.
SEE ACCORDING TO CNN REPORTING,
TODAY'S JURY SELECTION, INCLUDES
ROADS SURROUNDING THE
COURTHOUSE, STATIONED STIEPERS
ON THE ROOF.
A PERSONAL FAMILIAR WITH THE
SITUATION SAID PROSECUTORS ON
YOUR TEAM HAVE BEEN ISSUED
BULLETPROOF VESTS.
CAN YOU GIST DESCRIBE SOME OF
THREATS YOUR OFFICE HAS BEEN
GETTING?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THE AW DASDY
TO CONDUCT THIS INVESTIGATION
HAS MADE SOME VERY ANGRY.
WE ARE, OF COURSE, ALSO WORRIED
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF THE TEAM
THAT DOES INVESTIGATION.
WE DID NOT INTEND TO BE
INTIMIDATE BUT IN RECENT DAYS, I
EVER TURNED UP ON WHITE
SUPREMIST' PAGES THEY SEEM TO BE
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED MY OFFICE
HAS DONE I KNOW YOU HAVE REPORT
ON, THE ASIAN SPA KILLINGS AND
SO THOSE KIND OF THINGS, BRING
GREAT CONCERN TO THE SECURITY
THAT HAS TO PROTECT US.
>> IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING YOU
HAVE ALREADY MET WITH
FORMER-PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
ATTORNEYS, AT LEAST TWICE.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN SAY
WHETHER YOU MET WITH THEM
RECENTLY?
AND WHAT IS YOUR SENSE OF DID
ANYTHING WHERE COME OUT OF THAT?
>> UM, I HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM RECENTLY
AND I ANTICIPATE THAT WE WILL
HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS OVER
THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
I WOULD NOT SAY ANYTHING
FRUITFUL HAS COME OUT OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AT THAT POINT,
OTHER THAN RESPECTFUL DIALOGUE
ABOUT WHAT I PLANNED TO TO.
LAST YEAR, I MET WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL DOUBLE AND I
ASSURED THEM AT THAT PONY, THAT
I WAS GOING TO SIMPLY CONDUCT ON
INVESTIGATION TRYING TO ASK
WITNESSES TO VOLUNTARILY COME
IN.
AT THE END OF LAST YEAR --
DECEMBER TO BE EXACT -- I MET TW
THEM AGAIN TO SAY THAT AT THIS
POINT I WAS CONFIDENT THAT IN
THIS NEXT YEAR, BEING 2022, I
WOULD BE MOVING FORWARD SO WE
COPE KEPT OUR WORD ON THAT.
SQUO AND SO, IF THERE ARE THINGS
THEY WANT TO BRING TO ME, THEY
HAVE NO OBLIGATION TO HOO DO SO
BY IMHERE ARE, AND OPEN AND
WILLING TO LESSEN.
>> I WANT TO GO SOMETHING ABOUT
FAKE ELECTORS.
THE JUS TES DEPARTMENT SAID THEY
ARE -- TAKING A LOOK AT FAKE
ELECTORS.
ARE YOU AWARE OF THAT IN
INVESTIGATION -- INVESTIGATION
IN TERMS OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
GEORGIA?
OR HAVE YOU BEEN IN TOUCH WITH
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE?
>> I DON'T PLAN ON SPECIFICALLY
COORDINATING WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
WHAT THEIR SBREGZ WOULD BE IS
OBVIOUSLY ELECTION FRAUD ANY
GREAT PLACE IN THIS COUNTRY.
MINE IS MUCH SMARL.
A PILG INVESTIGATION BY MUCH
SMALLER.
I AM ONLY LOOKING INTO ELECTION
SBREENS IN THE STATE OF ZWRORM
GEORGE AND MORE SPECIFICALLY,
THINGS THEY ASKED FOR AROUND
THAT COOL THAT OCCURRED IN MY
COUNTY, MULTILEN COUNTY.
>> AND LASTLY, HOW CONCERNED ARE
THAT UNLESS YOU GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS, FUTURE LENGDSS
COULD BE SUBJECT TO THE SAME
KIND CLAIMS BY PEOPLE -- BY
ANYBODY?
>> WELL, MY BELIEF IS THE THAT
GOVERNMENT HAS LOT OF SPOMTS AND
DUTIES BUT TWO RESPONSIBILITIES
AND DUTIES ARE ONE, THEY DHIEFRP
SIT INCIDENCE SAFE WHICH IS THE
GREAT ROLE OF THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY.
AND, TWO, THAT IF WE LIVE IN A
FREE LAND IN A NOLK RASY, WE
HAVE TO HAVE FREE AND ELECTIONS.
AND SO I AM VERY CONCERNED IF
BEHAVIOR IS ILLEGAL GOES
UNCHECK, IT COULD LEAD TO
SIMILAR BAD START, A VERY, VERY
BAD PATH.
BUT I AM ALSO CONFIDENT THAT WE
WERE ABLE TODAY TO GET A
CROSS-SECTION OF THE COMMUNITY
THAT WILL